good day everyone this is Jack Van Horn
from the bd2k training coordinating
center located at the University of
Southern California and I'd like to
welcome you all to our next installment
of the big data to knowledge guide to
the fundamentals of data science and
today we're in section 4 and were
absolutely delighted to have Pavel
Penn's nurse from the University of
California San Diego presenting to us
today on algorithms and optimization and
dr. Besner is a professor of computer
science and engineering and the director
of the NIH a national center for
computational mass spectrometry at the
University of California in San Diego he
earned his PhD from the Moscow Institute
of Physics and technology in Russia and
was elected to the eighth as an ACM
Fellow in 2010 for his contributions to
algorithms for genomic rearrangements
DNA sequencing and proteomics he's also
a International Society for
computational biology fellow as well as
a has earned honors from the European
Academy of Sciences in 2016 an honorary
Doctorate from Simon Fraser University
in Vancouver Canada and has authored
several works with his colleague Philip
compo including textbooks on
computational molecular biology and
algorithmic approach introduction to
bioinformatics algorithms and
bioinformatics algorithms and active
learning approach and in 2013 he
developed a very popular bioinformatics
specialization on Coursera online course
series which was his own was a series of
seven different courses and has already
had over 300,000 enrollments and in 2006
also a jointly with the Philip compo he
developed a biology meets programming
online course in Coursera that
introduces out biologists to programming
methodology and so without further ado
I'd like to welcome dr. Posner and and
we're absolutely delighted to have him
and to hear what he has to tell us on
algorithms and off
station bubble 8 is yours st. John for a
kind introduction and good morning
everybody I was asked to talk on
algorithm in data science to people who
probably never took an introductory
algorithmic course and who probably not
must do not necessarily know how to
problem it's a tall order but I will try
and I want to focus in my talk on this
intersection of two walls one world is
worth of biology where problems are
somewhat imprecisely formulated in the
world of algorithm where you absolutely
need to be precise in everything to do
do it and I want to describe this bridge
between an extra mental researcher and
computational researcher when it comes
to problem formulation when problem
moves from biological world to
algorithmic world what is happening in
fact many people come to estimate the
complexity of this task it takes
enormous amount of time for professional
by informatician to transform a problem
from imprecise biological formulation
into an all-day problem let's start
let's start from something that has
little to do with biology the newspaper
Club imagine that you have hundreds of
identical quarters of New York Times and
you stack it on a pile of dynamite and
you light the fuse of course don't do it
at home and the answer is an explosion
and after this explosion many pieces are
burned but something Kistler and your
goal is to reconstruct the original New
York Times newspaper so what would you
do well you would look at tiny pieces
and treat them as a giant overlapping
puzzle for example when you look at
these two pieces
well probably they come from the same
place and he can't start assembling them
together and slowly but surely the hope
is that they will eventually assemble
the folders and you already have figure
out that I am actually talking about
genome assembly in these guys and my
goal would be to assemble the New York
Times front page a nonsense the
sequencing of draft human genome 17
years ago and since that time there was
enormous acceleration in genomic
sequencing and currently there are only
if you took at bacterial world there are
over 100,000 different bacterial secrets
and there are also huge efforts on
sequencing individual human genomes of
course and our newspaper problem
obviously translating the biological
problem when instead of New York points
we have multiplied carcass of a genome
and it breaks animate random position
the generate reads and of course some
not all reads from all positions of the
genome are present and as a result we
have this huge collection of reads and
for every rate we have no clue what
position in the genome it comes from our
goal nevertheless is to assemble these
pieces into each atom and we start
looking further up exactly like in the
journal in the newspaper problem look it
just found an overlap of two pieces
maybe we can glue them together and
continue in this way that sounds simple
the only problem is that they have
millions or in the case of human genome
billions of such pieces and any
reasonable algorithm that you use to
assemble a jigsaw puzzle even if you are
an expert in assembling let's say sounds
and pieces puzzles will fail
even with most powerful computer in the
world what would you do
so once again Oh setup we have at free
mental challenge but we solve it it
generated slid is read and finally we
need to assemble it how would we
formulate this assembly problem and I
want you to meet this people who
seemingly have nothing to do this modern
biology at least order and Hamilton I am
nothing to do this water boils end of
born well before modern biology was
developed but without them we wouldn't
be able to sequence genomes they came up
with this fundamental I mathematical an
algorithmic ideas that actually enable
genome sequencing today and I will try
to explain how their ideas propagated in
the modern biology as a result in fact
today many biologists for example loves
each on dbrand graph and currently many
biologists are broken could be so-called
reference rhythms in the future the
reference genomes probably do become
absolute notion because they need to
grow cuvees multiply genomes and human
genomes are very different and they need
to somehow represent this variety of
genome as something that people now
called
population graph or population genome
and this graph will be represented and
is currently represented based on the
idea developed by zit by debris and
going back actually to our environment
so let's see how would we solve a string
reconstruction problem and in our case
in the genome sequencing problem setup
we need first to rigorously family it
out there that's what I've done our goal
is to reconstruct the genome from reads
input to this problem a collection of
strings that recall reads
output is a string Gina reconstructed
from rate does it make sense does it
look like a rigorous statement that you
can pass to you algorithmic call it and
this person will solve this second look
seemingly looking reasonable formulation
is absolutely wrong this is not a
computational problem what many
biologists in face there is a problem or
exists would view it as something they
represent their challenges and maybe
exactly in this way if they would work
with algorithmic colleagues they would
represent their problem exactly like
I've done without understanding that it
is not a computational problem that your
colleague has let me explain why it is
not a computational problem
some time ago genius mathematician Georg
Cantor said to us right question is
harder than transit and the question
about on the slide is not the right
question to us and when we think about
problem formulation in biological
scientists it's good to think about the
sense of following context imagines that
you want to solve your biological
problems that require computational
tools but imagine that you never talk
I'll get it's mono and class and
imagines that you don't even know how to
product not to worry you can enter into
a million-dollar contract which is a
brilliant computer scientist Alice to
solve the genome sequence in prep but
keep in mind that Alice lives in a
bunker and the only way you can
communicate with alice is by passing her
a single page would use your problem
formulation
our problem formulation and Sabrina's
slide definitely fit on single page so
this will be satisfied this case
requirement will be satisfied now
however there are important rules for
communicating to visa Alice
should avoid biological charms Alice is
very busy or not to her only client
she has no ability to ask you any
question or to learn anything new well
genome she only knows computer science
as long as you violate the problem you
can be guaranteed
she will solve it but you need to
formulate the correct if you pass out as
a page of your stones like PCR she will
fall asleep she doesn't understand now
the next very important send your
problem may have multiplied
algorithmically correct but biologically
useless solutions and at least actually
is free to report any of them according
to the country she would prefer to
report and easy to find solution because
she is busy and collecting a million
dollar payment it is important that you
problem is formulated in such a way that
any solution returned by Alice bill
answers a question you are really
interested in it is not uncommon when
people family problems that allow to
give useless still formally correct
solution
another important thing make sure that
you can check that a list solution is
correct it will finally the problem
specify how to determine versus output
this correct given the input if it
doesn't if it does not can you even
check that Alice solution is correct
in the problems that I family today's
condition was violated and as a result
it did not represent good computational
problem and of course it is to say you
have to be specific precise short
elegant now this isn't mine let's move
towards a good algorithmic problem
formulation for genome assembly we will
introduce the concept of k-mer
composition given the genome k-mer
composition caner is simply a continuous
sub stream of a genome of landscape so
three male composition will be simply a
collection of all swimmers
from the strength I'll take a Liberty to
represent it on a single line but the
way I represented here is a little bit
of chicken because it assumes that I
know the order of this
Kaymer in my journal in reality I don't
know the order of the k-mers and that's
why I will represent them in
lexicographic order in the same way
people represent information and
telephone book so it's starting from all
streams starting from a and continuing
could be siient and then my string
reconstruction problem is will be
reconstructed stream from its k-mer
composition input is a collection of
k-mers it means your reads an output a
genome such that its composition is
equal to the collection of k-mers or
your input of course people working can
assembly would understand that it's a
gross oversimplification of reality but
let's start from this and then later we
will move to more adequate biological
problem formulation it's actually very
common approach in data science to start
from simplifying problem to develop main
ideas based on simplified problem
formulation and later move to problem
set better model real biological reality
now then I have the problem formulation
let's start solving the problem let's
even assume that I know which particular
streamer represents the beginning of the
genome then if it is taa is the first
one then the next one should start from
a a right so let's bring the next one
and we starting started assembling then
bring the next one so here it is then
brings the next one but now we have
three caner starting from T dream not a
problem so you simply have multiple
choices
let's select one of them here it is
let's continue facility mini pretty and
then at the next step we need to find
something starting from titi what look
you don't have any read starting from
titi which means that we fail so we need
to develop something that is a better
way of solving this assembly problem so
let me describe how biologists have been
solving this problem for a long time in
fact I am describing an approach that
was used for assembling the human brain
let's represent every caner as a node
and let's connect nodes corresponding to
the genome by arrows icons as arrows
algorithm is causes arrows edges and as
a result the sequence of the snow will
basically read the general but how do we
know so we've done a little bit of
chicken because they constructed this
graph assuming that we know the general
but can deconstruct this genome pass
from the first node to the last node
without knowing general only from its
composition it's the first glance it
looks yes we simply need to connect
Kaymer one we just came here to if
psychics of the first scanner equal to
the prefix of the second camera like
shown here and in this case they will
construct exactly the same path right so
that's what I've done but if you fall
through through that outline at the
bottom of the slide then you have an
obligation to connect every two k-mers
sides add suffix of the first one equal
to the prefix of the second one which
that you have to connect ATVs 83 and you
have to connect the 80 visited rain
continuing this way this is all the
connections that you have to make and
that's why the problem becomes more
complex and can be still find Audrina
Parsons this graph of course it stills
is horizontal fast but we forgot that we
do not know the order correct not of
nodes in this graph and if we order
nonsenses graph in the same way as we do
in the phonebook then the graph look
like this looks like very complex maze
and it's absolutely not clear how would
we assemble genome from this graph but
clearly we need to travel in this graph
starting again missed a continuum cursor
continuing further please note that
there are multiple choices it many steps
so we continue continue continue
continue and what are you trying to do
so they're given a graph which is
basically watch networks movies in the
case of genome assembly problems this
network will consist of minion cities
representing nodes and millions of roads
represented by edges and what we are
trying to do they are trying to visit
every node in the graph right because we
need to explain all reads every node
explained one knows rate so they
continue and in fact the problem they
are trying to solve is finding capacity
means that each node in a graph exactly
once to explain its rate and this
problem is known as a Hamiltonian path
problem in computer science input to the
problem is a graph in output Espace
visiting every node in the graph exactly
once and Hamilton started actually
introduced this problem by trying to
solve the
puzzles that I showed here how to visit
every node in this graph now human
gentleman did was assemble using
essentially a solution of a Hamiltonian
path problem how did it sophisticated
targeted for solving problems that are
similar to Hamiltonian Prospero
but well short naturalisation seconds in
converge people switch from this to
computational technology to something
else to completely new idea so let me
describe how more genomes are assembled
today and its user uses different
approach so this is my Hamiltonian
solution of Hamiltonian path problem for
this graph but it is not the only
solution this is another solution and of
course in a graph of these minions
reactances corresponding to real genome
sequencing problem there will be
billions of sections so what can we do
let's describe a slightly different
approach for constructing a graph that
models genome assembly remember this is
a old graph in this case our k-mers
represent nodes
I now want Kaymer's to represent a dress
trousers and nodes that seems like a
strange desire and it almost like
cosmetic modification or for what we are
doing wait a little bit and you see that
this is actually the matter idea that
completely turns the table in this game
so if you represent not know the
difference between previous pictures the
table that we analyzed and the new
picture now address sorry about base
right now but how do you label starting
Canadian nodes of every edge well of
course this should label the starting
node by a prefix of came here and ending
node by psychics of camera so that will
look like exists okay and that
represents now this picture represent my
journal
and now I do
that is completely extremely strange
I've asked you to do the following scent
while exist past a threat and start
gluing notes with his identical labels
for example a tee appears three times in
my genomic path I will glue them
together like I show here and they did
get closer together and finally glued
into a single note instead of C note a
tee
I do have one more take now I will
continue doing this I see three notes t3
in my Grod once again I can bring them
together and glues them in a single note
have you done not here because there is
also two no GJ I will bring them closer
together and that's what I do and where
is the dream I'm hiding in this graph
well neither simply just glue ink note
so Suzy know if just passing this graph
try to sync all address right so this is
my trend and a pass so that means that
each edge of the graph exactly once is
called
an honorarium pass please note the
difference in Hamiltonian paths we are
talking about positon is at every node
every what exactly once now we are
talking about pass that is it every edge
exactly once again seems like cosmetic
difference so we have now two problem
already and pass problem find the path
visit in cab reactions a graph exactly
once three hundred years old and it
started by Leonhard Euler the great
mathematician one of the greatest
mathematician of all time who asked a
question can he broke through through
the city of königsberg which had seven
bridges in such a way that you can visit
every bridge exactly once and return
back home and if you look at this city
and try to do this you will quickly see
that it is
not possible this problem was so
influential for genome assembly that the
reason when a company called seven
bridges that named seven bridges in to
recognizing the contribution of this old
puzzle to genome assembly now if you
look at this problem it's even difficult
to find the difference there is only one
difference here difference between low
damage why did I spend so much time
trying to present to you to simply mean
an ethical problem allow me to explain
so we have two problems now and give
this soul the distal problem correspond
to this two graphs with each graph would
you prefer well it's the first class you
would prefer the two block would be the
Griffons right because it is smaller but
that would be a wrong carbonate because
each of this graph will have millions of
the artists anyway maybe one will have
two million another five Monday
doesn't matter they all will be gigantic
so unless you know how to solve this
problem how to travel in this gigantic
graph you're going to find the key
reason why I introduced this is two
seemingly very similar problem is
because while euler solves the euler and
past problem even for a city with
billion bridges he suggested the genus
algorri that will solve this problem for
whatever size of the graph
nobody has developed a fast algorithm
for the Hamiltonian path problem even
for a city of a thousand nodes so two
algorithmic problems may look nearly
identical but they may be dramatically
different with respect to tractability
whether it's possible to develop an
algorithms as part
and it turn out that Hamiltonian path
problem becomes to a collection
containing thousands of computational
problems for which generations of
computer scientists failed to solve and
for sometimes I had a guilt feeling
because they said maybe they're stupid
and they can solve because in that the
reasons is good and solid but then the
situation has changed they started to
send selves they cannot solve it maybe
just maybe because nobody can solve it
because they're intractable in principle
that would be an excellent argument to
demonstrate your boss you cannot solve
this problem because nobody can solve it
because it is intractable but attempt to
do this are very complex it's actually
one of the so called millennium million
dollar prize problem to prove that
Hamiltonian path problem is intractable
and that's why computer scientist
developed a theory called NP
completeness theory and now the argument
to your boss has changed they prove that
all these problems that come thousands
of problems that Hamiltonian path
problem belongs to actually criminal and
since each of this problem for each of
this problem so we're very smart people
that we are trying to solve it then the
argument now I can't find an efficient
algorithm
but all this geniuses standing in line
also can find this efficient target
any answer that you probably heard
sometimes sometimes by information
towards a user torment P completeness to
refer to the problems that is hopeless
but in our case it looks like we should
follow the Euler path and Jakob is the
brain graph because all are proposed in
efficient target for solving the problem
however I don't know if you noticed but
I cheated in my talk be constructed the
d-brane graph from Jenna but reality the
genome is unknown
so yes older can solve older and past
problem in this graph but to construct
this graph you only have breeds you
don't have you don't have the genome the
kind of its defines the goal so what
we've done from Gina we know how to
construct the graph and from graph we
know how to find a genome in this graph
using carbanion but what we really have
behaved free it's only and our goal is
to construct the Jenna me now achieve
this goal in two steps first we will
construct the d-brane graph from reads
and then we applying over all the
rounded to find the genome in this graph
make sense so let's see how it's done
it's actually very easy so now we don't
have the genome the only hybrids but
let's do something could be Soviets and
let's represent every read as a single
edge between two nodes with each node
the first node will be the suffix of the
street and the second will be sorry the
first know what will be the prefix of
the street and the second node will be
the suffixes and then afterwards let's
do exactly what we did before let's glue
nodes with his identical labels so here
the glue scissors glue continue gluing
and look we are in the same position we
had before dig all the snow reads
magically glutens of genome pass but
that of course also cheating because I
haven't finished my glory I should
continue being encased before and after
I completed this I got exactly the same
graph from reads that I would get from
the dream didn't know the genome yet but
the paragraph of genome is exactly the
same as the brain graph of reads and
this is fundamental observation being
you're behind modern assembly out so one
more time to define the brain graph of a
collection of K maps for your collection
of chemistries of course collection off
let's say hundred nucleotide or 200 no
plethora of grid represent every camera
as an edge between its prefix and cited
and then glue all nodes who is identical
label that sounds almost renal but
that's how great ideas often are they
after you distilled everything they pay
amazingly elegant and simple so you may
be wondering why I melt on order and the
brain thought about this problem they
didn't send about this problem deeper
and in fact sought about the different
purely mathematical puzzle he wanted to
find a circle strand containing each
binary Kaymer exactly once so here all
binary Kaymer all strings ins alphabet
of zero and once and de bruin wanted to
construct a circle string that contains
each of the scammer exactly once adds
hissed at that time when he answers
question it wasn't even clear whether
it's possible or not and it's of course
not obvious if you do it for cane and
let's say not for the small cane when
you can explore it by hand but for
camera off reasonable size with
sub-sites hundred so once again in this
shot was ranked each of this eight three
males on the top appears once and how is
this problem is relevant to genome
assembly well the only thing we want to
do is to assemble these swimmers in to
examine like in the mega genome and what
we do they represent each of the care as
an edge between two nodes and then
simply glue elements nodes with is
identical levels and
have this graph this is the brand graph
for boolean strength and then we need
simply to travel in this graph to find
the solution of our problem
well in our case of very simple graph
the solution is clear but how would you
find the solution in the d-brane graph
of reads containing millions of nodes
and here it brings us to the next part
there I was hesitating whether I should
present it or not but then finally I
decided I should present it and I should
take you through the torture of proving
theorems because if I gave you token
algorithm and optimization in data
science without giving you an example of
how theorems are proved I will be
cheated because a hard work of computer
scientists also includes proving Sara so
please bear with me I will try to make
this proof very simple and even
entertaining and in the end you can ask
questions anyway let's go back to
finding the proper to solving the
problem of finding kind of Lunarian
cycle and so we want given a graph we
want to find a cycle that visits every
edge of the graph exactly once I have to
ask you some question is this graph
corner and end does it have a cycle
visiting Gabrielle exactly once of
course not because a rat left the
Atlantic's is a dead end right what
about this graph it's also no Taylor
already because there is no even way to
visit the red vertex there are no edges
entering and how about this graph this a
little bit more complex but if you look
at this vertex there is one edge
entering this vertex and two edges
getting count of the circles
therefore there is no owner and pass
visiting
all address in this graph because if you
enter in green note you have to leave it
right so to leave with two times you
have 20 at least two times also
so these are examples of non ordinary
anger and it also illustrate that every
Iranian graph should be balanced which
means the number of incoming edges in
every node equals to the number of
outcoming
edges for every node and if you look at
this graph the different constructed it
actually satisfies these conditions
right to note two edges entering every
node and to address leaving every node
so we just proved that everyone Aryan
graph is balanced but it doesn't tell us
yet
whether every balanced graph is already
okay and that's what we are going to
prove that if a graph is balanced which
means in every node there is the same
number of entering caches as the number
of outgoing edges then they can
construct in ordinary cycle
let's do this it will take me trust
three minutes so to do this we need to
recruit an end and we lack and randomly
walk through the graph and of course
since we need to visit every edge
exactly once there cannot use the same
air price now if aunt was a genius then
and would start working and simply
magically would pass through all edges
in the graph right and solve the problem
but the worst intelligent match the end
would go would start working it probably
would start somewhere so the and walk
randomly and in this case it actually
stuck in this node there is no
address out of the snow and zan has not
completed the Iranian walk yet what
should we do
he is a desert owner came up this you
know what and actually did a good job
he just started at the wrong note maybe
they can ask and to start at the
different note of what no what would it
be well if you look at this green cycle
there are some note on this green cycle
we still unexplored edges and why
shouldn't we do this why should not do
this stock adds a note to design explore
it edges right and still continue
working humans the green cycle but
starting from this no the point is that
when we returned back the will be an
edge to continual work let's do this
this is first at second short force but
now there is a possibility to move
further right we move further Mufasa
Mufasa Mufasa and they stuck again what
should we do well now you probably
figure out that we need to continue
working to learn the cycle that end just
completed but starting from a different
note what note should we select once
again note we still unexplored edges
which will be this note so what did the
once again we utilize the previous job
that the end it and walk along the
previous cycle so that's what we do now
we return back to the red node but we
can continue working some and continue
working continue working continue
working and finally and completed the
ovarian cycle the beauty of this proof
is that in it immediately implies very
efficient out for solving the
cycle problem because what I just
described was very essentially
algorithmic instruction to the and or to
your computer on how to find such thing
and the algorithm is very now when you
formulate when you broke collaboratively
with your computational College it's
very important to family a good problem
for them but it's also very important
that your problems adequately model
reality the problems that I described
doesn't more the reality of assembly and
that's why there are thousands of papers
on this topic and many many groups
Birkin conscious still up to this day so
in one they made some ridiculously
unrealistic assumption for example the
assume that there is perfect coverage of
genome by reason which means every came
here from the genome is represent by
reads is wrong of course in real
biological problem the assumes that
reads I here are free which is wrong
the assumes that multiplicity of came
also known many many wrong assumptions
are made here in fact in reality we have
perfect coverage desire pran
multiplicity of chaos are no and
computer scientists are now directness
know how to deal with this assumption
also of course modern assemblers is one
of the most sophisticated pieces of
hardware today of software in modern
biology and for example in the case of
imperfect read coverage the reception
counterintuitive as I do they actually
break every deeds into shorter cameras
to do assembly for example if you
generate 200 nucleotide Illumina reads
computer scientists will most likely
break them into let's say 55 nucleotide
rates to ensure better coverage by short
camera another sank what do they do this
Harrison reads well in this case if you
have a ruinous reason you perfect
genomic paths that will be looking
we'll be complemented by a bubble every
error creates a bubble in the graph that
is incorrect so when you move exam Gina
then for in addition to correct passes
in this graph corresponding to Gina
there are many many enormous number
bubbles made billions of bubbles and
your goal is to figure out how to remove
it in how to find the correct pass if I
use this graph definitely you would not
know where correct passes because I
would read through the bubbles so this
is another problem computer scientists
are trying to solve and of course I
cannot cover this into into the reasons
of time of this talk but let me give you
an idea so this is the main graph of
bacterial genome after all this problems
were addressed and I can tell you that
our internal d-brane graph oxygen movies
all bubbles would consist of probably
twenty thirteen million address so you
can appreciate the complexity of now I
use this example is just one section of
our course on bio by informatics
specialization of Coursera and the
textbook that we use for this course
that is freely available on as content a
part of our content delivery system and
we covered only one of the algorithmic
topics that we discussed in this course
last word and we connect various
biological problem with specific
algorithmic challenges for example
biologists do not really is a kinetic
mist often cross grown and Trust to
random chance to solve their problem for
example my chief regulatory my team
funding
heavily based on so-called randomized
algorithm when we toss a coin and here
you can see an artist drone me and my
colleague Phillip Campo trying to toast
coin on the table with some biological
quantum there
we currently discussed only one section
assembly the sample which is based on
graph algorithm we also discuss brute
force algorithms is another big area of
how that it's been big data and discuss
how they apply to sequencing
antibiotics of course we discuss
extremely important area of modern
computer science dynamic programming and
this is a workhorse behind your sequence
comparison out there we discuss
combinatorial algorithms is this
workhorse for example for study
rearrangements in the human genome we
discuss evolutionary tree reconstruction
using the story of SARS outbreak as an
example we are asked a question how did
this become a binary revolutionary as a
reason to discuss clustering algorithm
another huge part of big data analysis
that is applied to many problems in
biology the of course in this course
discuss how biologists finding
polymorphism in disease-causing mutation
and it brings another huge area in
algorithmic science which called
combinatorial automation they also
discuss the question of I have
biologists still nor develop an HIV
vaccine and describe the link of two
very important workhorse of many studies
in big data which is called hidden
Markov models or age well the also
discuss a question was to write just a
big chicken and
the area of computational project
exactly discussing support
so I want just to illustrate that I
covered extremely small fragment of
algorithmic status and big data and it's
big area and I sank my talk is coming to
the end but I still have time to send my
partner grant Phillip Campo professor my
former student who is now a professor at
Carnegie Mellon University that a
project would not be possible without
NIH at BP 2k problem and I also been
grateful to HHMI for professor Awards
that also contributed to the status and
of course be extremely grateful to
thousands and thousands of our Coursera
students who provided invaluable
feedback and continue providing kids so
our course is not static it's an
adaptive course in the sense that the
constantly updated based on the feedback
from the from our students and we are
also very extremely fortunate to have a
following of male over 50 professor at
various University who adopted our
content and essentially teach the same
story I just told you in one of the
classes and use our textbook for the
classes so they are very pleased there's
this verbs that was supported by NIH
HHMI was taken very positively but soon
by so many professors worldwide and I
think I finished a long time thank you
paavo thank you so much for a fantastic
talk entertaining and and funny and I
know ants are kind of known for working
hard but they work particularly hard in
your presentation there thank you so
much for that and want to encourage our
folks who are out there online or too
any questions that you may have for dr.
Posner via our question submission
system that's part of the go to webinar
system and I'll send those in and then I
will kind of pick and choose and read
them off to to Pavel and he can spend
some time addressing them so while there
people are thinking about those
questions one of the things which was to
be pretty obvious to me is that this
pattern of matching and marrying and
merging different nodes and different
models it seems like you would have
applications across a wide variety of
biological problems I mean in particular
like complex biochemical pathways and I
mean things I mean imagining like you
know the Krebs cycle here as just one
very kind of fundamental approach have
you tried to do any of that in your
courses or in any other of your research
in looking at complex biomedical
pathways and how you might decide
whether or not they're all Aryan or
Hamiltonian etc the absolutely right
different graph originally was proposed
for assembly but since that time here it
has become a workhorse in many different
areas of bioinformatics for example
antibody sequencing today which means
protein sequencing based on mass
spectrometry data is done based on the
brain gap analysis of immunise
sequencing data is also done based on
the brain graph analysis of synthetic
block is done based on the brain graph
and there are many many other
applications so it some of you may know
this concept of color of the brain graph
for representing human population
genomes so there are many application
and it's a only increasing right amazing
go ahead so it's just going to follow up
on that that it's it's really
interesting the potential applications I
kind of was was thinking about the many
of the instances where they're all kind
of discrete things right that
every node is kind of its own discrete
thing and the paths are basically there
there's a path between one node and
another and you can create these graphs
what happens if some of those edges in
these graphs what happens if they have a
weight attached to them so I guess for
example if your thing about the seven
bridges problem what if one of those
bridges is like you know drawbridge or
rather one of them is a narrower bridge
maybe it's a one-lane bridge or maybe
another bridge is it's not a bridge at
all but it's a zip line and so you can
get across really fast but you can only
you know have one person at a time
how do those kind of concept kind of get
factored into some of this modeling so
this concepts are very important because
when you can strike the breeding ground
for assembly all I didn't mention it but
all edges have weight in this weights
represent coverage of the correspondent
came in three times and then assembly
algorithms at our work and afterwards
taken to account and work hard with this
coverages because that's the way for
them to distinguish bulges from real
edges so this is waiting for amended all
in real applications edges awaited right
although of one of our listeners Adams
are we guaranteed at Dingell Euler path
for any given graph or sometimes we
arrive at more than one possible
candidate well in the case of next
generation sequencing could be a short
read it's almost all this even for
bacterial genomes around multiplied
passes and as a result biologists in
such cases use context rather than
various passes because if there are so
many passes it's not clear how to
represent them however who his
generation technology Pacific
Biosciences and Oxford nanopore the
graphs
become much nicer
and for many of them there is only
ovarian cycle for example for bacterial
genomes sample of this but Oxford
obvious Pacific Biosciences I sent in
eighty ninety percent of cases we
actually have a single cycle which makes
it very nice one of our other listeners
is asking in some of your own modeling
are you picking off the data from an
individual genome for say somebody you
know like my genome or would you say try
to fit these algorithms to reference
algorithms and then somebody else asked
you know is there basically they're
implying is there any way to do this
across people and then use all of these
graphs to kind of match the graphs
across people to identify kind of
cohorts or people with similar genomic
segments or sections if you will so
until recently it was pretty difficult
based on short periods to accurately
assemble human genome but I believe that
obvious long grids and more accurate
assemblies may indeed have huge number
of accurately assemble human genomes and
they will have no choice but to
represent them in the structure similar
to D programs and also there's a
question on are these possible for use
in applications in the structural
biology and could you apply them in
three or maybe more dimensions if
necessary that's an interesting question
I actually do not know it is not my
research area but would be very
interesting to see whether it is
possible I can tell you that new
applications are happening as we speak
there are more and more applications of
this concept people find but I did not
see applications in 3d biology yet right
and and do you find these are I mean it
looks like you've got a
some of your course materials been
adopted at 50 universities and Counting
within the last couple of years and do
you find that these sort of
methodologies these are catching on and
people this is starting to find purchase
in how people do genomic sequencing
using kind of the latest greatest
state-of-the-art techniques
well the courses are mainly for students
and they're still finishing their
studies but this ideas that I described
they're definitely behind dominant
assembly tools so they they are already
been there for the last ten years as I
mentioned Souza's human genome was
assembled using all the technology which
was quite a feat an enormous enormous
achievement but in the last ten yes
people are mainly using the outlines
that I described how do the companies
like the seven bridges people how do
they do things that may be different
than what you've it here
well seven bridges has I believe watch
research programs that is not
necessarily limited to assembly only
maybe it was something in the beginning
because but they have no journal large
reservoir by informatics company
so most of leading research in area
assembly is concentrated in places like
MIT between genome Institute in you know
British Columbia genome Center and other
places my own lab so I would say most of
efforts in this area actually happen in
Canada mirrors and in company
interesting is anybody who's working in
the field and they attempted to play
with algorithms which start with longer
k-mers to minimize possibly the number
of edges and nodes and
kind of simplify things and and try to
you know resolve things that were not
possible under the smaller size yes
people definitely want to play with
longer camera in fact yeah people at
university of hong kong who develop ID
be a popular DB assembler versa first
realize how to incorporate longer and
longer cameras in the de prendre
and they develop the concept of
iterative assembly when caner lens is
not fixed like in the setups that i
presented but is changing so in that
allows them to incorporate one became
our sensor framework well one one last
question is i wasn't quite clear on how
you identified the bubbles that you
mentioned in some of your birthday
Brewin grass
i'm sure that that's kind of a laborious
process to identify them and probably an
even more laborious process to decide
which ones are real and which ones are
in fact bubbles and can be popped if you
will just a little summary of how that
process happens and how long it takes
so humbly i simply represented this
short cycle in the graph right so that's
that's how it looks like because every
error in the read creates relatively
short they create basically a positive
pass we don't know now finding them is
not a problem it's actually difficult
not to notice them because there are so
many of them a period usually has an
error so imagine you have millions of
reads mean millions of models it's a
question is how to efficiently get rid
of them and how to kind of yet remove
them from the graph without destroying
the correct errors that's that would
take me another hour to cover maybe
we'll have to find it another hour for
you to explain that process it sounds
like that
kind of pretty laborious but at any rate
well listen everyone we've reached the
top of the hour here I want to thank a
professor prisoner from UC San Diego for
a really interesting and entertaining
talk on algorithms optimation
optimization and and graph theory and
bridges and ants and everything that he
covered is really truly a remarkable
presentation I think just fit perfectly
into our goals here through our big data
to knowledge guide to the fundamentals
of data science I want to thank you all
for for joining us today and thank you
again to dr. Posner and everyone have a
great weekend and we'll look forward to
seeing you next week thank you everybody
listen thank you